c'est un des mettront les plus modernes
de la planète est aussi eu des projets
qui a relancé copenhague fin des années
80 et la ville est moribonde chômage
élevé population en baisse endettement
on décède en 1992 d'ajouter un métro aux
trains de banlieue onze ans plus tard
les deux premières lignes du métro de
copenhague sont inaugurées sur une
distance de 21 km elle relie 22 stations
dont seulement 9 sont souterraines en 14
minutes à partir du centre-ville les
copenhague web désormais se rendre à
l'aéroport
le métro a coûté 2 milliards 400
millions de dollars ce qui est à peine
trois fois plus que le prolongement du
métro de laval avec ses 5 km et ses
trois stations une facture qui paraît
donc raisonnable mais ce n'est pas tout
le métro de copenhague et rentable
chaque jour nous faisons des profits
d'iparralde lanciers directeur des
transports à la ville qui a dirigé le
projet il explique que le métro est
complètement automatique
on le fait fonctionner à distance dans
un centre de contrôle il n'y a donc
aucun conducteur donc pas peau sans
conducteur nos dépenses d'opération ne
double pas si on double le nombre de nos
trains explique-t-il voilà pourquoi nous
en avons beaucoup et comme ils peuvent
être plus petit parce qu'ils passent
souvent nos stations peuvent elles aussi
être plus petit et moins cher à
construire le métro de copenhague à 34
ram composé de trois wagons chacune il
est en fonction 24 heures sur 24 passes
aux deux minutes à l'heure de pointe
le métro fonctionne à l'électricité et
roule à 40 km heure en moyenne en
incluant les arrêts
chaque jour colette julia entre la
station north porte la plus achalandée
de copenhague
elle adore son métro comme selon elle la
plupart des résidents je pense que c'est
un métro qui est très apprécié et brew
il ya eu des petits règlements à faire
au mois de mars on a eu 17 heures sans
métro parce qu'un câble électrique ne
fonctionnait plus mais ce sont des
petites choses en terme général il
fonctionne très bien et il est très
efficace
colette n'a jamais à franchir de
tourniquets l'entrée du métro
libre et c'est l'usager qui doit lui
même validé son billet
c'est une autre façon d'économiser des
coûts d'opération le métro de copenhague
n'emploie aucun personnel ni pour vendre
des titres de transport n'est pour
vérifier les allées et venues dans les
stations des contrôleurs circulent quand
même pour s'assurer que les passagers
ont bien payé leurs billets sans quoi
c'est la contravention dans cette ville
où les salaires sont plus élevés qu'à
montréal circuler en métro centre ville
coût 4 $ 80 à les surplus annuel amassés
par la vente de billets vont rembourser
environ le tiers de la dette contractée
lors de la construction
dix paires hals la ville de copenhague
et le gouvernement danois pense avoir
fini de rembourser leur métro dès
l'année 2030
parce qu'un autre mode de financement
apport beaucoup de revenus
un mode de plus en plus commun à travers
le monde qui s'appelle la captation de
la plus-value foncière bel 20 heures
james kramer mais quelle scène a été le
maire de copenhague 2,89 à 2004 il est
derrière l'idée d'avoir développé un
tout nouveau quartier auraient stade
entre le centre ville et l'aéroport
une bande de trois kilomètres carrés de
terres publiques
jadis vacante où passent maintenant le
nouveau métro
la construction du métro a fait
augmenter le prix des terres doré stade
et l'organisme que dirige aujourd'hui
jones mickelson a pour mission de faire
des profits en vendant les terres au
privé à ce jour il a ainsi amassé 400
millions $ pour payer la dette du métro
le soumettons un plan d'urbanisme à la
ville vendons les terres et choisissons
les architectes et les projets dit il
copenhague devrait payer 40 % de la
dette du métro par la vente de terrains
des conditions économiques plus
difficiles dans les années 2000 n'ont
pas aidé et elle en est aujourd'hui à
17% seulement mais plusieurs ter sont
encore à développer satisfaite de son
métro copenhague a donc décidé de
doubler sa superficie dans le sous-sol
de la vieille ville
le plus important projet danois defra
structure en plusieurs siècles est en
cours
le citizen kane une boucle entourant le
centre ville qui sera inaugurée en 2019
et coûtera 4 milliards et demi de
dollars
on sait que ça coûte cher pour ce que
c'est financée par nos impôts
mais bon on a un résultat je crois que
c'est assez propres à ce pays c'est vrai
que les apports sont lourds mais on sait
où il passe avec le site ihringen 85 %
des résidences et des employeurs du
centre-ville seront située à 600 mètres
et moins d'une station de métro
la valeur des maisons devrait donc
augmenter les taxes ou si une autre
façon pour copenhague de capter la plus
value foncière et financer son métro ce
n'est pas tout une quatrième ligne doit
aussi voir le jour pour 2021
elle servira à développer nord draven un
nouveau quartier d'avenir près de la mer
copenhague devrait donc passer de 0 à 30
9 stations métro en 20 ans